good morning John it is January 28th it
is a Wednesday yeah and this is a song
Wednesday so I'm about to do a song but
I have a little explanation first I will
have you know that this is the first
song that I'm recording on my new
MacBook Pro and I'm also recording it
with Final Cut Express so this is all
very new to me and I'm very confused but
I think that I've done an okay job
getting this together who's good that I
had Final Cut Express because this was
kind of a complicated song to do largely
because I couldn't sing it myself
because it's parody of another song and
that song is pretty far outside of my
range I'll show you at the end of the
video me trying to sing it so I got
Katherine to sing it for me and then I
lip synced over it because that is the
only way that she would agree to sing it
for me so this is a little weird because
I'm not singing I also didn't really
actually write the song but John and I
discussed it and he said that this is
perfectly okay for me to do parodies on
song Wednesday's he didn't say that it
was okay for Katherine to sing but there
was really no other way that this was
gonna get done so without further ado
stock advisor
[Music]
that's right I trusted my stock advisor
you said stocks we're always gonna go up
I look at you and it makes me want to
throw up you said that there were risks
out there but I could be a million just
like you just like me babe a market
crash ever since then I've been drinking
and I can't determine what exactly I was
thinking
[Music]
stock advisor socket stock advisor young
stock advisor
old stock advisor o yama stock advisor
baby thank you of course to Britney cuz
it never would have happened without you
girl you you you my stock advisor you
almost died investment analyzer I'm kind
of father that's right I trusted my
stock advisor and now I'm out of time
dftba